still turning
new twitter what the [ __ ]
what is this what is it what the [ __ ] is
going on
what's going on with the timeline
mine hasn't changed yet either what the
[ __ ] what's going on with the twitter
timeline someone put in the comments
somebody tell me what the [ __ ] going
on
i just i actually just uh downloaded the
uh the new twitter uh the update on the
twitter app with the new fonts and stuff
on my phone
and then yeah i'm not i'm not that
excited about it
and no
no not really i mean it's all right you
know i don't hate it the only thing i
hate is the follow-on file that changed
the color of the buttons they switched
it so it's real confusion like i thought
i was following this person you go
clicking you're like oh i was
[ __ ] me
do
what the hell is going on what's the new
twit what's the new twitter update what
the hell is going on what the hell is
going on
i'm really i'm really not
i'm not going to put up with this much
longer we got to get to the bottom of
this new twitter stuff people what the
hell is going on with this
what the hell is going on
let's tweet this
here's what i always do copy so i get it
right
boom
what the
[ __ ] is new twitter
you guys are watching me tweet live
that's the one i wanted
that's the gif
tweet you just watched a live tony
michael's tweet i think that's one of
the persons